This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。嘿，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在别处根本不敢进行的坦诚对话，而你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做，听听并吸取
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
the hard way，请在AHA电台应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我的脑子炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听T-W-O percent。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应得的报应。我们总是说
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners,
相信你的好闺蜜。在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。大家好，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个与大家探讨我们二十多岁的重大生活变化与转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎收听本播客。新听友，老听友，
wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today, we're tackling a very frequently requested topic and also one of the major concepts in psychology and how we conceptualize the self. So I'm actually quite surprised. that I've never done a full episode on this before. What I'm talking about is ego, that nasty feeling we all get sometimes that maybe we're a little bit better than others, that maybe we deserve
无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听另一期节目。今天，我们要探讨一个被频繁要求的话题，这也是心理学中的主要概念之一，以及我们如何概念化自我。所以我其实挺惊讶的。我以前居然从未就此做过一期完整的节目。我要谈的是自我（ego），那种我们有时都会产生的不快感觉，觉得我们可能比别人稍微优秀一点，觉得我们可能值得
more, that life is unfair to us, or we are somewhat too good for our reality. That feeling is a really hard one to come to terms with. None of us like feeling entitled, and I think we can often involuntarily ignore when those feelings come up because it's shameful to admit. But I also think that it is still very much part of the human experience as we're going to examine in this episode. There is such a long list of explanations surrounding why our ego is sometimes inflated, why we fear this way, what it's protecting us from, perhaps how it's actually really reflecting some of our more deeply rooted insecurities. Personally, I've been contemplating ego quite a bit recently, whether my reality and my self-perception is based on truth or some kind of false
拥有更多，觉得生活对我们不公，或者我们某种程度上比我们的现实要好得多。这种感觉真的很难接受。我们谁都不喜欢觉得自己有特权，而且我认为我们往往会不由自主地忽视这些感觉的出现，因为承认这一点很羞耻。但我也认为，正如我们将在本节目中探讨的那样，它仍然是人类体验中非常重要的一部分。关于为什么我们的自我有时会膨胀，为什么我们会这样害怕，它在保护我们免受什么伤害，或者它实际上如何深刻地反映了我们内心深处的不安全感，有这么长的一串解释。就个人而言，我最近一直在思考自我，我的现实和自我认知是基于真相，还是基于我对自己的某种虚假
idea of how I see myself. And that's not really to say that I'm up here sitting on a very high throne pretending to look down on others. You know, I think I'm way too Australian to ever have that perspective. I think I'd get cut down pretty quickly. But it's much more around am I actually worth the credit that I give myself or am I delusional? And also, is my confidence and my self-esteem really confidence or does it come off as arrogance? Is that how people might see it? And maybe that's something that you've been thinking about as well. But I think to understand ourselves and the self in general, we really firstly have to understand our ego. So we're going to discuss that today by kind of going back to some of our very rudimentary psychology and examining the very
看法。这并不是说我坐在高高的宝座上假装俯视别人。你知道，我觉得我太澳大利亚人了，绝不会有这种视角。我觉得我很快就会被现实打击。但它更多的是围绕着：我真的配得上我对自己的认可吗？还是我在妄想？还有，我的自信和自负真的是自信吗，还是会显得傲慢？别人可能会这么看吗？也许这也是你一直在思考的问题。但我认为要了解我们自己以及广义的自我，我们首先必须了解我们的自我。所以我们今天将通过回顾一些最基础的心理学，并检查非常
Freudian idea around ego and some of ego's friends like the id and the super ego. We're also going to discuss how ideas around ego have evolved and changed in the modern era to be one that's very synonymous with arrogance and self-importance and how that quality is valued in some cultures more than others. very interestingly, but also what impact that has on us. And some of the crucial signs, six in particular, that it might actually be your ego in control. I also think, like I reflected and was talking about before,
弗洛伊德关于自我的观点以及自我的“朋友”们，比如本我（id）和超我（super ego），来讨论这个问题。我们还将探讨关于自我的观念在现代是如何演变和改变的，使其成为傲慢和自负的同义词，以及这种品质在某些文化中比其他文化更受重视。非常有意思，但这也会对我们产生什么影响。以及一些关键迹象，尤其是六个迹象，表明可能正是你的自我（ego）在掌控一切。我也认为，正如我之前反思和谈到的那样，
being egotistical and being confident can be very, very similar and feel very similar, but they're definitely very different things. You know, ego is based in insecurity, in compassion, in the validation and success of yourself compared to others. Whilst I think confidence is very stable, it is this self-assurance that we know who we are, we know what we're about, and how we choose to treat the people around us. So we're also going to look at how we can tell the difference and how to shift from acting from a place of ego to acting from a place of self-esteem, humility and grace.
自负和自信可以非常非常相似，感觉也很相似，但它们绝对是截然不同的东西。你知道，自负植根于不安全感、同情心、以及与他人相比你自己的认可和成功。而我认为自信是非常稳定的，它是一种内心的笃定，我们知道自己是谁，我们在做什么，以及我们选择如何对待周围的人。所以我们也将探讨如何区分这两者，以及如何从基于自我（ego）的行动转变为基于自尊、谦逊和优雅的行动。
race. So I'm also going to give you four key tips around that, one of which is a little bit counterintuitive, but I promise you it makes sense when I explain it. So I can't wait to discuss this all with you today, the taboo of ego, the control it has over every single one of us, but also how do we accept it as part of human reality and really transform those urges to ones of self-confidence? So I think without further ado, let's discuss the real psychology behind our egos. We cannot understand ourselves and also our deeper self without first understanding the role and the influence of our ego. It's a vital part of who we are.
优雅。所以我也会围绕这一点给你四个关键建议，其中一个是有点违反直觉的，但我向你们保证，当我解释时它就会说得通。所以我迫不及待地想和大家一起讨论今天的话题：自我的禁忌，它对我们每一个人控制力，以及我们如何接受它是人类现实的一部分，并将这些冲动真正转化为自信？所以我想废话不多说，让我们探讨一下我们自我背后的真实心理学。如果不首先了解自我的角色和影响，我们就无法理解我们自己以及更深层次的自我。它是我们不可或缺的一部分。
And really, I think it's important to understand how it compels us to behave in certain ways and treat others as well. And innate to that understanding is examining and having a good grasp of the actual origins and the basics of ego because there's a few different ways of viewing it. Some of them are helpful. Some of them are less helpful. And I think with most psychological concepts that have been kind of extrapolated for everyday use, there is always going to be some diffusion of accuracy in how we use these terms and how we use the term ego and refer to it throughout our daily. lives. So firstly, let's distinguish between the general psychobabble pop culture understanding of ego and some of the deeper psychoanalytic research and characterization of what this is, what purpose
真的，我认为了解它是如何驱使我们做出某些行为并同样对待他人是很重要的。理解这一点不可或缺的前提是，要审视并深刻理解自我的真正起源和基础，因为看待它的方式有几种不同的途径。其中一些是有帮助的。有些则帮助不大。我认为，对于大多数被外推用于日常生活中的心理学概念来说，我们在使用这些术语以及在日常生活使用和提及“自我”这个词时，其准确性总会有所稀释。所以首先，让我们区分一下大众通俗文化中对自我的普遍理解，以及一些更深层次的精神分析研究和对其本质的刻画——它是什么目的
it serves, why it exists, because like I said, there is a big difference here. Psychologists have been defining and redefining the ego for many, many years. But we really need to start at Freud to get a good bird's eye view of what it was intended to explain. So Freud was the first psychologist to really introduce the idea of ego into this field. And I really cannot overstate the waves that his essay on this created at the time. And still to this day, I would say his initial paper on this is possibly one of the most influential or famous papers ever written in the field of psychology. It has created entirely new fields of research and studies for generations because of how novel his ideas really were. So for Freud, our ego is really attached to our sense of self.
它起到什么作用，它为什么存在，因为就像我说的，这里面有很大的区别。心理学家多年来一直在定义和重新定义自我。但我们真的需要从弗洛伊德开始，才能对它原本旨在解释的东西有一个宏观的认识。所以弗洛伊德是第一个真正将自我概念引入这一领域的心理学家。我真的无法过分强调他关于这方面的文章在当时所引起的轰动。直到今天，我仍然可以说他最初关于这篇论文可能是心理学领域写过的最具影响力或最著名的论文之一。由于他的想法是如此新颖，它为几代人开辟了全新研究领域和研究方向。因此，对弗洛伊德而言，我们的自我确实与我们的自我意识息息相关。
And in Latin ego literally means I or me or self. So our unconscious mind also referred to as the self. So in some ways, the same as ego, it's controlled by three things. three unique influences who are all striving for control. Firstly, the ego, and then we have the id, and finally the super ego. So the last two are kind of left out of our conversations on this, because they're seen as kind of secondary characters to the main player here. So our id is this very primitive, instinctual, wild part of our mind
而在拉丁语中，自我字面意思是“我”或“自己”。所以我们的无意识心智也被称为自我。所以在某种程度上，它与自我相同，受三件事控制。三个争夺控制权的独特影响因素。首先是自我，然后是本我，最后是超我。所以后两项在我们的相关讨论中有点被遗漏了，因为它们被视为这里主角的次要角色。所以我们的本我是心智中非常原始、本能、狂野的一部分，
that is in control of things like aggression, like our sexual, urges. It's driven by what Freud called the pleasure principle. So that's part of our mind, which many of us try to suppress the kind, you know, the part of our mind, which is really striving for deep, emotional, primitive release, the instant gratification of all of our desires, all of our wants and our needs, really at whatever cost. Now, if we let that sign of us run freely, it would be incredibly socially disruptive and chaotic. So this is where our super ego comes in. And this is the subconscious part of our mind
它控制着诸如攻击性、性冲动等事情。它由弗洛伊德所谓的快乐原则驱动。所以那是我们心智的一部分，我们许多人试图压抑它，你知道，心智中真正渴望深度、情绪化、原始宣泄的部分，即刻满足我们所有的欲望、所有的渴求和需求，无论付出什么代价。现在，如果我们任由这一面自由驰骋，那将在社会上造成极大的颠覆和混乱。所以这就是超我登场的时候了。这是我们心智的潜意识部分，
that kind of acts as a counterbalance to that really wild, unruly, instinctual part of us. So if the id in this situation is kind of the devil, the super ego is really the angel, kind of the holder of all of our deep moral instincts, our desire to be good. And importantly, the super ego is what contains all of those internalized moral standards and ideals that have been passed from generation to generation from our families, from our parents, from our society.
它起到一种制衡作用，对抗我们那狂野、不羁、本能的那一面。如果本在这种情况下有点像恶魔，超我则真正像天使，它可以说是我们所有深层道德本能的守护者，是我们向善的愿望。更重要的是，超我包含所有那些从一代又一代人、从我们的家庭、从我们的父母、从我们的社会中传承下来的内化道德标准和理想。
It's really our sense of right and wrong that tries to, in some ways, civilize us. So the id and the super ego are kind of in this deep battle for control of our mind. And our ego is the parent here. Our ego is the final decider. So what our ego needs to do is balance both of these things and try and come to some kind of decision about how we act. And I think these days, we really think of the ego as synonymous with things like arrogance or a really expanded unnatural sense of self-worth. But for Freud, our ego was the part of us in control of reality, the part of us which takes in all of the urges and the impulses from the id and then all of the good intentions of the super ego and makes an informed decision about
它真的是我们的对错感，某种程度上试图使我们文明化。所以本我和超我在争夺心智控制权的这场深层博弈中。而我们的自我在这里扮演着家长的角色。我们的自我最终的决策者。所以我们的自我需要做的是平衡这两者，并试着就我们如何行事做出某种决定。我认为如今我们真的把自我与傲慢或夸大且不自然的自尊感等同起来。但对弗洛伊德来说，我们的自我才是控制现实的那部分，它吸收来自本我的所有冲动和欲望，以及超ur的种种善意，并对
how we want to represent ourselves to the world, what actions we actually want to take. So I'm going to give a quick example here to kind of really nail on this point. Say you've been dating someone for a few months and they do something that really annoys you. Maybe they stand you up, maybe they forget to text you back or they get too drunk or do something stupid. In that moment, the anger and the annoyance that we're bound to feel is going to come from the id. And this part of you might really want to lash out to be furious, to give them the silent treatment, to do the things that might make you feel in the moment a lot better, but that we know in the long run are probably actually going to sabotage that relationship.
我们如何向世界展示自己、我们到底想采取什么行动做出明智的决定。所以我在这里举一个简单的例子来真正阐明这一点。假设你和某人约会了几个月，他们做了一件让你非常恼火的事。也许他们放你鸽子，也许他们忘记给你回信息，或者他们喝得太醉或做了什么蠢事。在那一刻，我们注定要感受到的愤怒和烦恼将来自于本我。而你这一部分可能真的很想爆发，变得暴怒，对他们冷暴力，去做那些可能让你当下感觉好一点，但我们知道从长远来看实际上可能会破坏这段关系的事情。
So on the other side, we have our super ego. And this is the part of us that is pushing us to forgive, to act in a way that is very emotionally pure and also at times perhaps a little bit too passive and the ego's role here is to balance both of those perspectives and act in a quite rational self-fulfilling way. So for Freud, having a strong, well-checked ego meant having a strong sense of self-awareness. However, when that ego becomes unbalanced or misaligned to our reality, that's when we start to see what we would call egotistical behavior where we are not really seeing reality and our role and place in reality clearly enough and we're kind of elevating ourselves beyond perhaps where we actually stand
所以在另一边，我们有超我。这是我们心智中促使我们原谅、以一种情感上非常纯粹且有时可能稍微有点过于被动的方式行事的部分，而自我在这里的角色是平衡这两种视角，并以一种相当理性且自我实现的方式行事。因此，对弗洛伊德来说，拥有一个强大、经过充分检验的自我意味着拥有强烈的自我意识。然而，当这个自我失去平衡或与我们的现实脱节时，我们就会开始看到我们所谓的自负行为，即我们没有足够清晰地看到现实以及我们在现实中的角色和位置，并且我们把自我抬高到了客观上
objectively. This unbalanced overinflated ego is really what's aligned with our present day conceptualization. It's kind of used more as a synonym of our sense of self-esteem or our sense of self-importance, how we see ourselves in relation to others, to our successes, to our mistakes, and our sense of self-worth. And this is the perspective that we're going to take today. Our ego is that combination of all of those hidden aspects of our mind, our insecurities, our urges, our values, our morals. And when it's out of balance, that's when we begin to see those behaviors that society tells us are not particularly desirable. But I think what's important to note is that all of those behaviors that we see is connected to being egotistical is really an effort by our
我们实际站立的位置之上。这种失衡且过度膨胀的自我，确实与我们当代的概念相契合。它在某种程度上更多地被用作我们的自尊感或自重感的同义词，即我们如何看待自己与他人、与我们的成功、与我们的错误以及与我们的自我价值感的关系。这就是我们今天要采用的视角。我们的自我，是所有那些心智中隐藏方面的结合体——我们的不安全感、我们的冲动、我们的价值观、我们的道德。当它失衡时，我们就会开始看到那些社会告诉我们并不是特别理想的行为。但我认为需要指出的是，所有那些被我们视为与自负相关的行为，实际上都是我们的
subconscious mind to protect us, to protect our reality, to protect our sense of self-esteem through things like arguing or putting others down or passive aggressiveness, intolerance, blame, competition, distrust, self-doubt. So what does it look like when there's part of ourselves that it's very normal and natural to have is dysregulated and in control. What are some of the signs to watch out for that we're falling into a bit of an ego trap? So I'm going to outline six in particular that perhaps your ego has more control of your life than we would like it to. Number one, you are noticing that you always need to be right.
潜意识为了保护我们、保护我们的现实、通过争吵、贬低他人、被动攻击、不容异己、责怪、竞争、不信任、自我怀疑等方式来保护我们的自尊感而做出的努力。那么，当那部分对我们来说既正常又自然、却又失调并掌权的自我出现时，会是什么样子的呢？有哪些迹象表明我们正在陷入某种自我陷阱中，需要多加留意？所以我将特别概述六个迹象，表明你的自我对你生活的控制可能比我们希望的要多。第一点，你注意到自己总是需要正确。
So the ego is at its core the picture of ourselves that our minds have created to balance our self-image, all of our wants and the contents of the self. And our subconscious mind wants that sense of self, particularly our positive sense of self-esteem, to really be maintained. Because when it's injured by things like rejection or embarrassment, it can cause really emotional and mental pain that can feel quite profound. And one thing that can challenge that kind of equilibrium and that can make us feel bad is being wrong, because it causes us to question our version of reality. Normally, when our ego is in check, it can really take on those mistakes. It's okay to be wrong and to be corrected by other people. We take that with humility. We integrate
所以自我的核心，是我们心智为了平衡自我形象、所有欲望和自我内容而创造的关于我们自己的画面。而我们的潜意识希望这种自我感，尤其是我们积极的自尊感，真正得以维持。因为当它受到诸如拒绝或尴尬等事情的伤害时，它会引起非常深刻且触及心灵的情感和精神痛苦。而一件会挑战这种平衡并让我们感觉不好的事情就是犯错，因为它会让我们质疑我们对现实的认知。通常，当我们的自我受到抑制时，它其实可以接受这些错误。犯错并被别人纠正并没有关系。我们以谦逊的态度接受这一点。我们将之整合
that into our understanding. We're okay to move past that. But when our ego is overinflated, we become incredibly defensive. We all have that experience of being friends with someone who, no matter what has to be right, who corrects you instantly when you slip up. I like love this saying of like the actually friend, you know, well actually, that's not right. Actually, that's what this really means. It's not a pleasant experience. And the reason people act this way is because they are projecting a deeper insecurity that their ego is unable to keep in check. Perhaps that they aren't smart enough or they aren't intelligent. So they feel the need to overcompensate. to regulate their self-esteem by always being correct.
到我们的理解中。我们能够释怀并继续前进。但当我们的自我过度膨胀时，我们会变得极其防备。我们都有过这样的经历：和某个无论如何都必须正确、在你口误时立即纠正你的人做朋友。我喜欢这种说法，比如“其实”朋友，你知道，“嗯，其实，那不对。其实，这才是真正的意思。”这可不是什么愉快的体验。人们之所以会这样，是因为他们投射出了一种更深的不安全感——他们的自我无法对其进行控制。也许他们觉得自己不够聪明或不够智慧。所以他们觉得有必要过度补偿。通过总是正确来调节自己的自尊。
That is a huge sign of an overinflated ego because the healthy ego would be able to manage being wrong without reacting in a way that lets the id and lets those insecurities take control and really act in a way that satisfies the hunger and the need and the gratification of being right. Number two, you're never happy with what you have. If you feel constantly dissatisfied with what you have, you're kind of. consistently comparing yourself to others, what they have that you don't, feeling like you should be entitled to that, and therefore maybe acting out of a place of jealousy or envy, that's a really huge sign that your ego is in control.
这是一个自我过度膨胀的巨大信号，因为健康的自我能够在不用激起本我和让那些不安全感接管、并真正以满足“正确”的饥饿感、需求和快感的方式做出反应的情况下，应对犯错。第二点，你对自己拥有的东西永远不满意。如果你对拥有的东西感到持续的不满，你某种程度上会
That entitlement is an indicator that perhaps you are not providing yourself with enough challenge, with enough growth, but also with humility. It's okay to sometimes fall victim to a bit of social comparison. and we know that it's a very innate biological evolutionary urge to compare ourselves in order to mediate our own expectations and our own behavior. But when it comes from a place of almost anger, that's what indicates that your ego is looking for some kind of success or material possession or a sign that you are good enough to validate your self-esteem.
不断地拿自己和别人作比较，看别人有什么而你没有，觉得自己理应拥有这些，因此可能会出于嫉妒或羡慕而行事，这绝对是一个巨大的信号，表明你的自我正在掌权。这种特权感是一个迹象，表明你可能没有给自己提供足够的挑战、足够的成长，同时也缺乏谦逊。偶尔沦为社会比较的牺牲品是正常的，
We think that people who have more money or more followers or more friends or have those really nice clothes or better items than us, we think that they are better. When really what we should be measuring our happiness and success by is the contents of our life, of our emotions, of our sense of fulfillment. That's something that the healthy ego can do. It can reflect on our beautiful attributes and what we do have. So when we're constantly feeling entitled to want more, to have more, to tear others down who might be doing better than us, That's again a sign that the ego is in control. Very similar to this is that you find yourself judging others more often than usual.
我们也知道，为了调解我们自己的期望和行为，将自己与他人进行比较是一种非常本能的生物进化冲动。但当它带着某种愤怒的色彩时，这就表明你的自我正在寻找某种成功、物质财富或能够证明你足够优秀以验证你自尊的迹象。我们认为那些有更多钱、更多粉丝、更多朋友、或者拥有比我们更好看的衣服或更好物品的人，他们就更好。而实际上，我们应该用来衡量幸福和成功的标准，是我们生活的内容、我们的情感、我们的成就感。这是健康的自我能够做到的事情。它能够反思我们美好的特质以及我们确实拥有的东西。因此，当我们不断觉得理所当然地想要更多、拥有更多、贬低那些可能比我们过得更好的人时，
This is what we call downward social comparison. And it's very easy to get a momentary spike in our self-esteem when we're feeling inadequate by making others feel worse about themselves. In psychology, downward social comparison is a defensive tendency that occurs when we deliberately compare ourselves to people who we perceive as worse off or worse than us as a way to elevate our own sense of self-worth. This might also manifest in thinking that you're too good for some people, too good to talk to them, too good to include them, to be friends with them, to show them compassion. That's honestly one of my biggest pet peeves.
这也是自我正在掌权的迹象。与此非常相似的是，你发现自己比平时更频繁地评判他人。这就是我们所说的向下社会比较。当我们感到不足时，通过让别人对自己感觉更糟，很容易在我们的自尊心中获得短暂的飙升。在心理学中，向下社会比较是一种防御倾向，当我们故意把自己与那些我们认为不如自己或比我们糟糕的人进行比较时，就会发生这种倾向，以此来提升我们自己的自尊感。这可能也表现为认为自己比某些人优秀、好到不屑于和他们说话、好到不屑于包容他们、和他们做朋友、向他们表现出同情。老实说，这是我最大的痛点之一。
I have this very deep belief that no one is better than anyone else. There are very few people in this world who do not deserve your respect. You know, I met people when I was at uni, and the way that they treated me and kind of others as well and turned their nose up at people who they didn't see as fitting into the in-group or being cool, that left such a powerful impression. You get nothing out of making other people feel bad just so that you can feel better. And it's very short-lasting. It closes you off, and also people will remember how you made them feel. And I think that's an important part of being a good person and being a good human. Very similar to what I mentioned before, someone who is sure of themselves, who has a consistent,
我内心深处坚信，没有人比其他人更好。这个世界上极少有人不值得你尊重。你知道，我在上大学时遇到过一些人，他们对待我和其他人的方式，以及对那些他们认为不属于核心圈子或不够酷的人嗤之以鼻的态度，留下了如此深刻的印象。你通过让别人感觉不好来让自己感觉更好，这是毫无益处的。而且这种感觉持续时间很短。它会封闭你自己，而且人们会记住你是如何对待他们的。我认为这是作为一个好人和一个好人类的重要部分。与我之前提到的人非常相似，一个对自己充满信心、拥有持续、
sustainable sense of self, shouldn't have to rely on these kinds of mental or social tactics. So if you find yourself kind of walking down the street and judging others, almost internally commenting on what they're wearing, critiquing other people's actions, thinking to yourself, I would never wear that, I would never do that. really pull back for a second and contemplate why you're doing that. Where is this urge coming from? Is that your ego talking? Is that your ego's need for self assurance and reassurance?
可持续的自我感的人，是不必依赖这些心理或社交策略的。所以如果你发现自己走在街上时对别人评头论足，几乎在内心里评论他们的穿着，批判别人的行为，心里想着：我绝对不会穿成那样，我绝对不会那样做。请停下来一秒钟，好好想想你为什么这么做。这种冲动从何而来？那是你的自我（ego）在说话吗？那是你的自我对自我确证和安心的需求吗？
Or is that actually your reality? So number four, you cannot manage failure. Your sense of self quite literally cannot take it. It would just further injure your self-concept. So you act in ways that are incredibly self-sabotaging. you withdraw, you procrastinate, you express undue frustration as a way of protecting that ego. And I think very similarly to this. And number five is that in those situations where you are experiencing failure, you blame others when
还是这其实就是你的现实？所以第四点，你无法应对失败。你的自我意识简直无法承受它。那只会进一步伤害你的自我概念。所以你的行动方式具有极强的自我毁灭性。你退缩、你拖延、你表达不合时宜的沮丧，以此作为保护那个自我的方式。我认为与此非常相似的是。第五点是在你经历失败的情况下，当
things go wrong rather than taking personal accountability. So in psychology, we have this distinction between an external and an internal locus of control. And it's this theory that articulates how different people, will make up different reasons for why something didn't go their way. People with an internal locus of control, they believe that they are responsible for their own successes and they can change things about their behavior
事情出错时，你倾向于责怪他人，而不是承担个人责任。所以在心理学中，我们对外部控制点和内部控制点进行了区分。这个理论阐明了不同的人会为为什么事情没有按他们的预期发展找出不同的理由。拥有内部控制点的人，他们相信自己要为自己的成功负责，并且在结果
when an outcome is perhaps not what they wanted. So if they encounter failure, they appreciate their own role in that and what lesson they can take from that experience. In contrast, people with an external locus of control, they blame things outside of them. Factors like other people, like luck, fate, a rigged system, they blame all of those things for their situation.
可能不如预期时，他们可以改变自己行为的某些方面。因此，如果他们遭遇失败，他们会珍视自己在其中的角色以及他们能从该经历中汲取什么教训。相比之下，拥有外部控制点的人，他们会责怪自己以外的事物。诸如其他人、运气、命运、被操控的系统等因素，他们将所有这些归咎于自己的处境。
And they don't believe that they are accountable for what they're encountering in their life. Not only does that contribute to learned helplessness in which people really devalue their own agency, but it also can indicate, once again, that your ego is overinflated, unbalanced, or in control. role, especially when it comes to finding reasons to excuse things that may hurt your sense of self-importance. You can't feel bad about something if it's not your fault. So if your ego really needs protecting, it will attribute situations that prompt guilt or humility to things that are beyond our realm of agency. It's actually one of my favorite concepts in psychology because it's very noticeable, I think, within others when they have an external locus of control versus an internal one.
而且他们不认为自己应该为生活中遇到的事情负责。这不仅助长了习得性无助——人们在其中贬低自己的能动性，而且再次表明，你的自我过度膨胀、失衡或处于掌权状态，尤其是当需要寻找借口来解释那些可能伤害你自尊感的事情时。如果不是你的错，你就不会感到难过。因此，如果你的自我真的很需要保护，它就会把那些引发内疚或谦逊的情境归咎于超出我们能动性范围的事物。这实际上是我在心理学中最喜欢的概念之一，因为我认为当别人表现出外部控制点与内部控制点时，这是非常显而易见的。
Something that I noticed a lot was people who complain about a test and maybe a test that's like really, really hard. And they say that the reason they failed was that, you know, someone was talking too loud, that the teacher had made it way too difficult, that the examiner, the teacher had it out for them. That might be true. Sometimes those things are true, but it also might be that that external locus of control is finding a way to protect your self-esteem and protect your ego. The final sign of a dysregulated, over-inflated, unbalanced ego is arrogance and feeling like you deserve more from life or other people because you have some quality, some unique attribute that others don't have. This is a common theme, I think, throughout those other five indicators we've discussed, but I think it deserves
我注意到的一件事是，有人抱怨一场考试，也许是一场非常非常难的考试。他们说自己没考好的原因是：有人说话太大声、老师把题出得太难了、考官或老师在针对他们。那可能是真的。有时这些事情确实是真的，但也有可能是那个外部控制点在寻找保护你自尊和自我保护的方法。一个失调、过度膨胀、失衡的自我的最后一个迹象是傲慢，并且觉得因为自己拥有某些别人没有的特质或独特属性，所以自己理应从生活或其他地方得到更多。我认为这是我们讨论过的前五个指标中一个共同的主题，但我认为它值得
its own spot because arrogance presents itself a lot more overtly. Arrogent people need to be the center of attention. They don't like compromise. They expect special treatment and they have what we would call a superiority complex. It's interesting to me because this sounds very similar to certain personality disorders, particularly narcissism. And actually there have been some theories that a permanently dysregulated ego or an injured subconscious might actually be behind the existence of these people in our society. Those who have this preoccupation with their own self-importance, they're really entitled, they're interpersonally quite exploitative. Narcissism, however, is a diagnosable disorder and our ego is just a part of us, right?
拥有自己的位置，因为傲慢表现得要公开得多。傲慢的人需要成为注意力的中心。他们不喜欢妥协。他们期望得到特殊对待，并且拥有我们所谓的优越感。这很有趣，因为这听起来与某些人格障碍非常相似，尤其是自恋。事实上，有一些理论认为，长期失调的自我或受损的潜意识实际上可能是我们社会中这些人的根源。那些全神贯注于自身重要性的人，他们有着极强的特权感，在人际交往中具有剥削性。然而，自恋是一种可诊断的障碍，而我们的自我只是我们的一部分，对吧？
There can be times in which it's overinflated, in which it's acting beyond what appears to be our sense of control where we are acting from a place of arrogance, but it doesn't mean that it has the same lifelong implications and the same kind of status as a personality disorder. Also, our ego is a lot more flexible. It can be kind of bended back into check when it's triggered to protect us. And there's a few things that can do this that might have caused an ego shift or an overinflation just temporarily. number one is a long string of successes or failures. These both act as unexpected events that alter our reality and our sense of self-worth, and they cause our ego to kind of have to adjust,
有时它可能会过度膨胀，其表现超出我们的控制感，导致我们表现出傲慢，但这并不意味着它会产生与人格障碍相同的终身影响和相同的状态。此外，我们的自我具有更大的灵活性。当它被触发以保护我们时，它可以被扳回正轨。有几件事可以做到这一点，这可能会导致暂时的自我转变或过度膨胀。第一点是一连串的成功或失败。这两者都充当了改变我们现实和自尊感的意外事件，它们导致我们的自我不得不进行调整，
and that delay is what can cause that arrogance or that overinflation. Things like bouncing back from a breakup, sometimes we really elevate our self-confidence or our ego really steps up to the plate and makes us feel a sense of self-importance or entitlement, to make up for the fact that actually deep down, we're really quite hurt. Really similar to that is situations that make you feel really emotionally uncomfortable. So I have an example of this. I have this one ex who I have always felt really inferior around.
而这种延迟正是导致傲慢或过度膨胀的原因。比如从分手后的阴影中恢复过来，有时我们真的会提升自信心，或者我们的自我真正挺身而出，让我们产生一种自我重要性或特权感，以此来弥补这样一个事实：其实在内心深处，我们真的很受伤。与此非常非常相似的是那些让你感到情感上极度不舒服的情境。我有一个例子。我曾有一个前任，我在他身边时总是感到自己很卑微。
And now, when I run into this person at parties or, you know, out in the street, I feel this like insane urge to just become an egotistical monster because of all that historical insecurity. And I respond by being like the complete opposite of who I am. I always try and make it seem like I'm doing so amazing and almost like brag about myself. And afterwards I always really cringe because that's a really ugly part of me that I'm not really used to seeing.
现在，当我在派对上或在大街上偶遇这个人时，由于所有那些历史上的不安全感，我内心会涌起一股疯狂的冲动，想要变成一个自负的怪物。我的反应表现得与真正的我截然相反。我总是试图表现得我过得好极了，几乎是在自吹自擂。事后我总是感到十分尴尬，因为那是极其丑陋的我，是我很不习惯看到的。
This false version of me that's kind of coming out and trying to impress this person who I genuinely could not care less about at this stage, I can see now that that's because my ego in that moment is being triggered by those past events that have caused me emotional pain, that have caused me to feel bad about myself. And so it's trying to create almost a sense of being better or being entitled or being successful as a way to protect myself from having to feel those feelings around that person again. our minds operate in such funny unconscious ways to help us out and sometimes in trying to help us actually it acts in a really counterproductive contradictory way and creates more trouble and sometimes i think we think that confidence and i think about that in that situation we think that confidence and ego are the same things or we confuse our ego with confidence and that's a distinction that i really want to explore
这个虚假的自我浮现出来，试图给这个人留下深刻印象——尽管在这个阶段我对这个人可以说是毫不在乎，我现在可以看出，那是因为在那一刻，我的自我被那些曾经给我带来情感痛苦、让我对自我感觉糟糕的过去事件所触发了。因此，它试图创造一种优越感、特权感或成功感，以此来保护自己，免得再次在这个人面前体验到那些感受。我们的心智以如此滑稽的无意识方式运作来帮助我们，但有时在试图帮助我们的过程中，它实际上以一种适得其反、自相矛盾的方式行事，制造了更多的麻烦。有时我想我们会认为自信——我想到了那种情况下的自信——我们认为自信和自负是同一回事，或者我们将自我与自信混淆了，这是我真正想要探讨的区别。
How can we tell the difference between when we're experiencing perhaps just a high self-esteem versus an untamed ego? They can feel really similar. So I really want to discuss that next, along with how we can shift from acting from a place at ego to a place of self-love, humility, and compassion. So all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness,
我们如何分辨我们经历的究竟是高自尊还是未被驯服的自我？它们感觉非常相似。所以我接下来真的很想讨论这一点，以及我们如何从基于自我的行动转变为基于自爱、谦逊和同情心的行动。这一切以及更多内容，就在这段短暂的广告之后。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the results. of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier,
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即在I-Hart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听T-W-O-O-Persent。
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule to never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist.
任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，千万不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说相信你的好闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在这个新季的《The Girlfriends》中，“天哪，这是同一个人。”一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会。
I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
我觉得自己就像被卡车撞了一下。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎，所以她们自己采取行动。我说：“哦，见鬼，绝不。”我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应得的报应。收听《The Girlfriends》。
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
Trust me, babe。在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMAs上拍了两次小金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what we're going to. down and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack.
好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析我们要讨论的内容。深入探讨并试着理解我们是如何熬过那段时光的。包括最近一期有马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）作嘉宾的节目，大谈80年代的可卡因。要说明的是，84对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。
I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
我随时都可以谈论可卡因，但为了让大家知道。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二期节目了，所以我开始看出这里有一条贯穿线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了桌面上，所以。然后你把那句话说完。是的。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得作为一个在世的好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两种不同水平的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。
Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have. have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. I think there is a very thin line that separates our self-esteem from our ego. It's something I contemplate a lot, especially as a woman, because sometimes I think society likes to misconstrue our self-confidence and our self-assurance as arrogance. but there is a distinction. And I think villainizing self-confidence won't actually do anything to soothe our ego.
加入我和Keir Gaines，我们在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中真实探讨治愈、成长、父职、压力和人生目标。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序，搜索Learn the Hardway并立即收听。我认为，自尊和自我之间有一条非常细微的线。这是我经常思考的问题，尤其作为女性，因为有时我认为社会喜欢将我们的自信和自我确信曲解为傲慢，但它们是有区别的。而且我认为妖魔化自信并不能真正起到舒缓我们自我的作用。
I think we can still have those qualities of being really amazing and claiming our power and knowing our worth and having a stable ego. Additionally, I think we all benefit every now and again from a bit of an ego boost. It's nice to feel like you're admired or you've done something right. and we don't want to fall too deeply into humility because that can sometimes actually contribute to poor self-esteem when we can never kind of take credit for our successes and our hard work and we can never take a compliment. And doing so doesn't mean that your ego is out of control. You're allowed to feel proud of yourself for your accomplishments without trying to call yourself back into check and tell yourself to be humble and to settle down.
我认为我们仍然可以拥有那些非常了不起的品质，宣示我们的力量，了解我们的价值，并拥有一个稳定的自我。此外，我认为我们所有人偶尔都会从自我提升中受益。感觉到自己受人仰慕或者做对了某事，这种感觉很好。我们不想陷入过度的谦卑，因为当我们永远无法为自己的成功和辛勤工作邀功，也永远无法接受赞美时，这实际上有时会导致糟糕的自尊。这样做并不意味着你的自我失控了。你可以为自己的成就感到自豪，而不必试图把自我收回并告诉自己要谦虚、安分。
I think when our ego is actually activated, that comes off very, very differently. It comes off as self-entitlement and arrogance. You know, that need to be right, that judgment. That is all coming from a deep detachment from ourself. At the core is this insecurity. And what I mean by that is that our ego is once again acting as a way to protect us from being injured by things that it thinks will hurt our sense of self-concept. additionally it's quite relational so it's quite comparative and almost based on the existence of others so our ego only really ever acts out in front of other people and it's very loud in the presence of others because it's often in those situations or when we are put in a position where we feel the need to compare ourselves to others that our ego is triggered and so we self-enhance we fluff out our feathers that is almost a defensive mechanism
我认为当我们的自我真正被激活时，表现出来的感觉是非常非常不同的。它表现为自我特权感和傲慢。你知道，那种对正确的渴望、那种评判。这全都源于与自我的深深疏离。其核心是不安全感。我的意思是，我们的自我再次充当了一种保护机制，保护我们免受那些它认为会伤害我们自我概念的事情的伤害。此外，它具有很强的关系性，因此它是相当具有比较性的，几乎基于他人的存在，所以我们的自我实际上只会在别人面前表现出来，并且在别人面前非常喧闹，因为通常在这些情况下，或者当我们被置于需要将自己与他人进行比较的境地时，我们的自我就会被触发，于是我们自我膨胀，羽翼丰满，这几乎是一种防御机制。
In contrast, self-confidence exists regardless of the actions, the opinions, or the presence of others. Ego comes from that instability within the self, but confidence comes from certainty and trust in ourself. And like I said, it's very separate and irresponsible to others. Confidence is always going to be there regardless of what other people think of you, regardless of whether other people around, because it is an internal source of reinforcement. of validation compared to ego which is seeking the approval and validation of others. I think the other distinction is that ego is counterproductive and it causes us to act in ways that are not aligned to our true selves, whereas self-confidence comes from knowing that true
相比之下，自信的存在与他人的行动、意见或存在无关。自我来自于内部的不稳定，而自信来自于对自我的确定和信任。就像我说的，它与他人非常独立且不相关。无论别人怎么看你，无论周围有没有人，自信总是会存在，因为它是内部的强化和认可源泉，而自我则是寻求他人的认可和验证。我认为另一个区别是，自我会适得其反，导致我们的行为与真实的自我不一致，而自信则来自于了解真实的自我并在其中感到舒适，信任我们的选择和决定。
self and being comfortable in that, trusting our choices and our decisions. And whilst ego responds to distortions in reality, you know, feeling like we're better than others or at times that we are maybe undeserving of things. Confidence is really rooted in the truth. I know my value. I know who I am. I know what I bring to the table. And we can recognize the difference and when ego versus confidence is in control a few ways. Firstly, you can tell when your ego is triggered versus when you're responding from a place of self-esteem based on the direction of your energy. So let me clarify this. if someone insults you, your ego will ask you to respond by tearing them down, finding a way to undermine them and prove that their opinion is wrong or invalid,
虽然自我会对现实的扭曲做出反应，比如觉得自己比别人好，或者有时觉得自己不配得到某些东西。但自信真正植根于真相。我知道我的价值。我知道我是谁。我知道我能带来什么。我们可以通过几种方式识别这种区别，以及什么时候是自我还是自信在掌控。首先，你可以通过能量的方向来分辨你的自我何时被触发，以及你何时在从自尊的角度做出反应。让我澄清一下：如果有人侮辱你，你的自我会要求你通过贬低他们、寻找方法破坏他们并证明他们的观点是错误或无效来做出回应，
that you don't need to listen to it, perhaps by identifying something about them that you don't like or some personal fault. Confidence, on the other hand, doesn't care of what they said is true. It might be true. This person might believe it, but we don't mind. We don't care. And so you don't need to respond by retaliating. You don't need to respond by reinforcing your self-worth by bringing that person down.
或者通过指出一些你不喜欢他们的个人缺点来回应，而你不需要去听。另一方面，自信并不在乎他们说的是否是真的。这可能是真的。这个人可能相信这一点，但我们并不介意。我们不在乎。所以你不需要以牙还牙地回应。你不需要通过贬低对方来强化自己的自我价值。
But you dismiss the comment, you hold your head high, and you provide that own positive self-affirmation through your own means rather than through your comparison to someone else. Confidence will never rely on you needing to feel better than someone else. But ego often does rely on that false sense of superiority. Secondly, ego feels uncomfortable and confidence feels safe and healthy. When we act from that place of an overinflated ego, all of that insecurity that is driving this response will still exist after the fact. It's not going to go anywhere. You're still going to feel bad.
而是驳回评论，昂首挺胸，通过你自己的方式提供积极的自我肯定，而不是通过与他人的比较。自信绝不依赖于你需要感觉比别人优越。但自我通常确实依赖于那种虚幻的优越感。其次，自我感觉不舒服，而自信感觉安全和健康。当我们从过度膨胀的自我出发行动时，驱动这种反应的所有不安全感在事后依然存在。它不会消失。你仍然会感觉不好。
You're still going to feel unstable. That deflated self-esteem will remain. And you'll almost feel, I would say, emotionally hung over from. that overactivity of your ego. When you're relying on your confidence, you will still feel that sense of reassurance. Your emotions are going to remain stable because once again, that is based on how you feel about yourself, not based on some relational or social comparison. Finally, we see the difference in how we treat others based on what part of ourselves a situation is activating. someone whose ego is inflated or misaligned, who is letting perhaps their id dominate,
你仍然会感到不稳定。那种崩溃的自尊心依然存在。我甚至会说，你会感到一种来自自我过度活跃的“情绪宿醉”。当你依赖自信时，你仍然会感受到那种安心感。你的情绪将保持稳定，因为这再次取决于你对自己的感觉，而不是基于某种关系或社会比较。最后，我们可以看到我们对待他人的方式有所不同，这取决于情况激活了我们自我的哪一部分：一个自我膨胀或失调、可能让本我主导的人，
will make other people feel bad about themselves. They will leave people feeling uncomfortable. They will suck the energy out of the room. They will exclude others or keep people at a distance. But people who are acting from a place of true, unique, authentic confidence, they make other people feel safe. They let them know that they are wanted in those spaces, that they are interesting, that they are comfortable in those spaces, they encourage them,
会让人对自身感觉不好。他们会让人感到不舒服。他们会吸干房间里的能量。他们会排斥他人或与人保持距离。但那些从真实、独特、真正的自信出发行动的人，他们会让其他人感到安全。他们让他们知道在这些空间里是受欢迎的，他们很有趣，在这些空间里他们很自在，他们会鼓励他们，
they make them feel good rather than making them feel uneasy. So how can we act from a place of confidence and self-esteem rather than ego? And maybe a better question, how do we rein that ego in, and act from a place of genuine self-assurance? Because I think no one likes feeling motivated by insecurity, or I guess feeling disappointed in their arrogance, or the momentary entitlement. So how do we replace ego with positive self-esteem and humility?
让他们感觉良好，而不是让他们感到局促不安。那么，我们怎样才能从自信和自尊的角度出发行动，而不是从自我出发呢？也许更好的问题是，我们如何控制那个自我，并从真正的自我确信出发行动？因为我认为没有人喜欢被不安全感驱使的感觉，或者对自己的傲慢或短暂的特权感感到失望。那么，我们如何用积极的自尊和谦逊来取代自我呢？
I think the biggest thing to realize is that you are not your ego. Your ego is just one element of who you are, not your totality. And equally as important is that your ego is within your control. When you can feel it flaring up, kind of rearing its ugly head or dysregulated, you can call it out, speak to it as a separate entity. kind of like a mean friend or like a negative internet troll. You know, just saying, you know, no, we don't do that anymore. That's not who we are.
我认为最需要意识到的一点是，你不是你的自我。你的自我只是你的一部分，而不是全部。同样重要的是，你的自我是在你的控制之下的。当你能感觉到它在爆发、露出丑陋的头或失调时，你可以把它叫出来，把它当作一个独立的实体来对话。有点像一个刻薄的朋友或一个负面的网络喷子。你知道，就是说，不，我们不再那样做了。那不是我们。
We don't say those things. We don't think those things. That's not the truth. It actually almost embarrasses your ego. And it kind of breaks the fourth wall, letting you see the reality of your thoughts more logically and clearly. Those are still your thoughts. You are in control of them.
我们不说那些话。我们不那样想。那不是真的。这实际上几乎让你的自我感到尴尬。它有点打破了第四面墙，让你更合乎逻辑、更清晰地看到你想法的现实。那些仍然是你的想法。你在控制着它们。
You can adjust them accordingly. Secondly, focus on what you feel you're objectively good at. What qualities about yourself do you admire? This might sound like it would maybe encourage egotistical thinking, but we know that our ego actually flares up most of the time when our sense of self is threatened or compromised. So finding a sustainable source of self-worth stops you from needing to leverage other people's apparent inferiority
你可以做出相应的调整。其次，关注你觉得自己客观上擅长什么。你欣赏自己的哪些特质？这听起来可能会鼓励自负的想法，但我们知道，大多数时候，当我们的自我意识受到威胁或损害时，自我才会爆发。因此，找到一个可持续的自我价值来源，可以让你不再需要利用他人表面的低人一等来让自己感觉更好。
to make yourself feel better. I want you to make a list of five things you are good at, five things you love about yourself and your five best qualities that are independent of other people. I don't want to see things like, you know, I'm a good parent or I'm a good daughter or I'm a good partner. We want qualities that are wholly yours, that you trust in, that you admire about yourself, even if other people were not around. This serves as like almost a private reserve of good thoughts for those days when you're maybe feeling a little bit emotionally wounded or you're feeling down and your ego may try and overcompensate. It kills that need to seek approval and validation from others. And you know, external validation is such a fickle thing. It's very inconsistent.
我希望你列出五件你擅长的事，五件你爱自己的事，以及你独立于他人的五个最佳品质。我不想看到诸如“我是个好父母”、“我是个好女儿”或“我是个好伴侣”之类的话。我们需要完全属于你、你信任的、即使周围没有其他人你也欣赏自己的品质。这就像是为那些你可能感到情感受伤、情绪低落、自我可能会试图过度补偿的日子准备的私人好心情储备库。它消除了寻求他人认可和验证的需求。你知道，外部验证是一件如此善变的事情。它非常不稳定。
It's not a stable sense of self-worth. but we can provide a stable sense of self-worth by reinforcing what we like about ourselves, what we think we're good at, what we know we're good at. Thirdly, let yourself be wrong, let yourself make mistakes, allow yourself to kind of have a bit of a laugh at yourself. I think taking ourselves too seriously and arrogance go hand in hand, because implicit to that assessment is that your actions matter more than others, that you have to hold yourself to a higher standard because you need to feel
这不是一种稳定的自我价值感。但我们可以通过强化我们喜欢自己的地方、我们认为自己擅长的东西、我们知道自己擅长的东西，来提供一种稳定的自我价值感。第三，让自己犯错，让自己犯错误，让自己稍微嘲笑一下自己。我认为把我们自己看得太重和傲慢是齐头并进的，因为这种评估中暗含着你的行动比别人的更重要，你必须对自己抱有更高的标准，因为你需要感觉更好、看起来更好、比别人更好。
feel better, look better, be better than other people. That's a lie your brain is telling you. Everyone in this life will make mistakes and they will be wrong at times. So being comfortable with that reality, adjusting to that exposure and that experience of embarrassment by turning it into a positive thing, by having a laugh at yourself, that really slowly conditions our sense of self-esteem and our sense of self to deal with failure and to not let it critically injure our self-esteem and our self-concept. Fourth is to see the good and others. Give them love and generosity and compliments and compassion rather than seeing them as some
那是你的大脑在对你撒谎。生活中的每个人都会犯错，有时也会犯错。因此，适应这种现实，通过把尴尬变成积极的事情、嘲笑自己来适应这种曝光和经历，这确实会慢慢调节我们的自尊心和自我意识，以应对失败，并不让它严重损害我们的自尊心和自我概念。第四是看到他人的优点。给予他们爱、慷慨、赞美和同情，而不是把他们视为某种嫉妒或羡慕的源泉。
source of envy or jealousy. You know, I think having a career on social media really breeds this social comparison a lot and I really personally hate feeling like I need to be more like someone else or that my content isn't good enough because I don't get X number of listens or Y number of likes. But a saying I really love is that someone else's success isn't the absence of your own. Just because someone else is talented doesn't mean you're not. Those things are not finite. There is a lot of the pie to go around.
你知道，我认为在社交媒体上拥有职业生涯确实会滋生这种社会比较，我个人真的很讨厌觉得自己需要更像别人，或者觉得我的内容不够好，因为我没有获得X数量的听众或Y数量的点赞。但我真的很喜欢的一句话是：别人的成功并不代表你自己的缺失。别人有才华并不意味着你没有。这些事情不是有限的。蛋糕很大，足够分。
And I think reverting to treating people like competition rather than as friends and really people deserving of your encouragement, it actually just devalue. use your own self-confidence because you're constantly looking at them for validation rather than looking at yourself. You're constantly trying to see how you kind of line up to see whether you meet this standard. So I would say really look for things that you admire about people, look for things about them that are really beautiful, look for the things about them that are really human and wonderful and let them know that. Kind of spread that love. It will make you feel better. it will make other people feel better.
我认为回归到把人们当作竞争对手而不是朋友，以及真正把人们当作值得你鼓励的人对待，这实际上只会贬低你自己的自信，因为你不断地向他们寻求验证，而不是看着自己。你不断地试图看自己如何排队，以查看自己是否符合这个标准。所以我想说，真正寻找你欣赏的人的优点，寻找他们身上真正美丽、真正人性化和美妙的地方，并让他们知道。传播这种爱。这会让你感觉更好，也会让别人感觉更好。
It will lessen that sense of needing to be in competition with the people around you. And finally, I would say, ask yourself why? Why do you feel like you need to be better than everyone else so that maybe you are better than everyone else? Why do you feel this entitlement? Where is this belief coming from? Is it a childhood insecurity? Is it poor self-esteem? Is it that you maybe want a little bit more from your life?
它会减轻与周围人竞争的需要感。最后，我想说，问问你自己为什么？为什么你觉得你需要比所有人都要好，以至于你可能比所有人都要好？为什么你会有这种特权感？这种信念从何而来？是童年时的不安全感吗？是自尊心低下吗？还是你可能对生活有更多一点的期望？
and you feel like you're not providing yourself that opportunity right now. Everything has an explanation, including our ego, and I do think we have a duty to get to that root cause, deconstruct it, and replace it with real, authentic, pure confidence, with self-love and gratitude for what we do have and who we are. There are some other things that I think are really important practicing gratitude. I just mentioned that. That is one of them.
而你觉得你现在没有给自己提供那个机会。凡事都有解释，包括我们的自我，而且我确实认为我们有责任找到根本原因，将其解构，并用真实、地道、纯粹的自信，用对我们所拥有的一切以及我们是谁的自爱和感激来取代它。还有一些我认为非常重要的事情，那就是练习感恩。我刚刚提到过。那是其中之一。
Sometimes, like I said, one of the signs that our ego is, in control is feeling like we deserve more from our lives or feeling like we deserve more from others being constantly dissatisfied. But when you really reflect on what you do have and that you don't need to achieve what others have achieved or have what they have to be okay with your life, that's a great way of reining your ego in. It's a hard reality to realize that there's always going to probably be someone better than you, you know, on that kind of scale that we see. There's always going to be someone making more money or who has more friends or is more successful or any marker of success or accomplishment, you know, it's very hard for us to be number one. A lot of people are number two,
有时候，正如我所说，我们的自我失控的迹象之一就是觉得我们应该从生活中得到更多，或者觉得我们应该从别人那里得到更多，从而感到永远不满足。但当你真正反思你所拥有的一切，并意识到你不需要实现别人所取得的成就或拥有他们所拥有的东西来对自己的生活感到满意时，这是控制自我意识的好方法。这是一个残酷的现实：在这个我们看到的规模上，总会有人比你更好。总会有人赚更多的钱，或者有更多的朋友，或者更成功，或者任何成功或成就的标志，你知道，对我们来说成为第一是非常困难的。很多人是第二、
three, four, five, six. So that is just as valid as a place to be. And you can still be happy with that and move on with your life. I think that's something that I find really important is to list the things that I am grateful for in my life, the things that I'm envious of myself for creating, you know, that my past self would be like, wow, that's so cool. And I can just be really grateful and appreciate the moment that I'm in. I think that's all I have for today, all my information on ego for this episode. I really hope that you enjoyed it, that it provided a bit of clarity, knowledge if this is something that you're struggling with. I promise it's not something to feel shame towards. It is a very natural normal part of just being a human. Is our ego fluctuating from time to time trying to make us feel
三、四、五、六名。所以这同样是一个合法的位置。你仍然可以对此感到高兴并继续你的生活。我认为我发现真正重要的一件事情是，列出我生活中感激的事情，我为自己创造的那些让我过去的自己会觉得“哇，太酷了”的事情。我可以真正心怀感激并珍惜我所处的时刻。我想这就是我今天关于这个插曲的所有的自我的信息。我真的希望你喜欢它，如果这是你正在挣扎的事情，它能提供一点清晰度、知识。我向你保证，这并不是一件需要感到羞耻的事情。这只是作为人类的一个非常自然正常的组成部分。
better or compensate for things going on in our life. So I really hope that this has been informative, that it's taught you something about how to handle those kind of ugly emotions every now and again. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you're listening right now, Google Podcasts. I don't know if that's a thing. Maybe I should check that out. And make sure you're following or subscribed and sent it to a friend if this is something that they need to hear. We also have a Patreon. I say we.
我们的自我会不时波动，试图让我们感觉更好或弥补我们生活中的事情。所以我真的希望这能提供信息，它教给你一些关于如何处理那些偶尔出现的丑陋情绪的方法。像往常一样，如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify、你现在正在听的任何地方、Google Podcasts上留下五星好评。我不知道那是不是真的。也许我应该去查查看。确保你关注或订阅了，如果这是你的朋友需要听到的，请发送给他们。我们也有Patreon。我说我们。
It is actually just me doing this. I write all my own episodes. I record them, produce them, release them. And it's a lot of work. So I really appreciate when people show their support and decide to kind of have a look behind the scenes and access some of that bonus content and also support me on the way.
实际上只有我一个人在做这件事。我写了我自己的所有节目。我录制、制作、发布它们。这有很多工作。所以我真的很感激当人们表达他们的支持并决定幕后花絮并访问其中一些奖励内容并在路上支持我时。
So there is a link in this episode description if you want to check it out. And finally, if you have a podcast suggestion, maybe there's an episode that you want me to cover. Please feel free to reach out to me at that psychology podcast. This episode was actually a suggestion from a listener. And I'm really sorry, I forgot your name, but I think you know who you are. Thank you for a wonderful suggestion.
所以如果你想查看它，本集简介中有一个链接。最后，如果你有播客建议，也许有你想让我报道的一集。请随时通过那个心理学播客联系我。这一集实际上是听众的建议。我很抱歉，我忘了你的名字，但我认为你知道你是谁。谢谢你提出了绝佳的建议。
I really do like kind of crowdsourcing ideas every now and again from what you guys are going through, the experiences of your 20s or just your life as a human being. So follow us over there for video content and just to kind of see what's coming out, see what's happening. We will be back next week with another episode, so thank you for listening. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
我真的很喜欢偶尔从你们正在经历的事情、你们20多岁的经历或仅仅作为人类的生活中众包一些想法。所以关注我们的视频内容，看看有什么新内容，看看发生了什么。我们下周会带着另一集回来，所以谢谢你的收听。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人Kear Games带来的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不安全的诚实对话，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。这向世界发出了一个信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through.
仅仅因为你有这个能力并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，欧文斯女士，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同一件事的男人。
the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app,
格雷格·吉利斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。在IHeartRadio应用程序上收听《2%》。即TWO percent，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们开始自己采取行动。我发誓。我会成为他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女友们。在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是人类制作的。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。